Mais quoi ? Dieu habiterait-il véritablement sur la terre ?
Voici les cieux des cieux, pardon, les cieux et les cieux des cieux ne peuvent te contenir.
Combien moins cette habitation que j'ai t'ai bâtie ?
Et donc là, nous sommes devant l'une des périodes les plus importantes de la Bible,
notamment de l'Ancien Testament.
C'était une aspiration qui a duré longtemps.
C'était une réalité qui a été expérimentée déjà de manière un peu plus faible,
un peu moins puissante, un peu moins intense, par les vies de certains hommes des dieux.
On peut penser à Abraham, la Bible les considère comme un ami des dieux qui parlait à Dieu.
Moïse également, avant la construction de Tabernacle,
il avait le privilège de se retrouver avec Dieu dans sa tente,
l'attente de la rencontre.
Et nous voyons de quelle manière les hommes ont pu avoir le privilège
de contempler quelques manifestations, quelques théophonies
qui donnaient à l'humanité l'apparence de la présence des dieux.
Mais ici, cette promesse devient quelque chose de plus collectif,
de plus communautaire.
Et la réalité de cette visitation des dieux, elle est incroyable.
Là, devant les temples,
Israël ne serait plus
entrant
de vivre en tant qu'il pèlerant
envers la terre promise,
mais
Israël va réjouir
d'une certaine stabilité, même si temporaire.
Et donc,
ils ont pu construire ce temple
qui a été, par la grâce des dieux,
honoré par cette visitation.
Donc, les versets 10 qu'on a lus,
au moment où les sacrificateurs sortirent du lieu sans,
la nuit remplit la maison de l'Éternel.
Les sacrificateurs ne purent pas y rester
pour faire les sacrifices
à causer la nuit,
car la gloire de l'Éternel
remplissait
la maison de l'Éternel.
Donc, ici, on a
cette expérience
glorieuse
qui devrait être
l'aspiration
de tous les êtres humains.
Que Dieu puisse
nous visiter,
que Dieu puisse
habiter entre nous,
que nous puissions avoir
un accès
à ce dieu
qui est évidemment
pour nous tous
un dieu
transcendant,
inaccessible
pour plusieurs raisons.
Mais la réalité,
c'est que Dieu
a visité,
Dieu a démarré
dans ces temples.
Donc, nous sommes devant
l'un des moments
les plus glorieux
de l'Ancien Testament.
Nous sommes devant
un fait.
Dieu est descendu
pour visiter Israël.
Nous sommes devant
l'accomplissement
d'une promesse
attendue depuis longtemps.
Et nous sommes surtout
devant l'assimilation
de la merveille
de ces faits.
Quoi ?
Dieu habiterait-il
véritablement sur terre ?
Est-ce que c'est
vraiment possible ?
Et ça montre déjà
une disposition
des cœurs
qui devrait être
la marque principale
de ceux qui veulent
véritablement
contempler Dieu.
Car lorsqu'ils
les êtres humains
méprisent Dieu
ou sa présence
ou sa visitation,
ils montrent
que leur cœur
n'est pas au bon endroit.
Si nous n'avons pas
ce sens de merveille,
c'est car on est
rempli d'arrogance.
Une arrogance
complètement déplacée
de notre nature.
la fragilité
de notre race
et l'aspect
moral
totalement corrompu.
Et la réalité,
c'est que Dieu
nous a créés
pour trouver
la joie suprême
dans la contemplation
de sa gloire
et dans la réjouissance
de sa présence.
Donc la plus grande
aspiration
qu'on puisse
jamais désirer,
c'est que Dieu
fasse sa demeure
entre nous,
c'est que Dieu
nous visite.
Donc c'est
un aspect merveilleux
qu'on doit trouver
chez nous.
Et ensuite,
Salomon fait
une prière
de consécration.
Il va prendre
cet espace
et il va
souplier Dieu
que cette demeure
non seulement
soit la demeure
où il a pu
contempler
une visitation
primaire
de Dieu,
mais que cette demeure
soit consacrée,
que cet espace,
cet homme soit consacré
pour toujours
en tant qu'habitation
de Dieu.
Donc son désir
n'est pas tout simplement
que Dieu vienne
de temps en temps
visiter cet espace
mais c'est que cet espace
devient pour toujours
un lieu
d'habitation
perpétuelle,
des constances
de la présence
des dieux
avec les peuples.
Et bien sûr,
que nous devons
savoir reconnaître
les distinctions
entre les temples
qui avaient un rôle
central à jouer,
nous allons comprendre
ces rôles,
et les églises
aujourd'hui.
Donc on n'a plus
cet aspect
central
par rapport
à un espace
qui doivent jouer
en rôle
si important
qu'il est temps
dans l'Ancien Testament
car les temples
de l'Ancien Testament
étaient en type
et en symbole
du Christ
qui est déjà venu.
Et c'est notamment là
qu'on ouvre
la connexion
de ces textes
non seulement
à cette question
de l'inauguration
d'un nouvel espace
pour l'Église
Bonne Nouvelle,
mais c'est un texte
qui s'apprête aussi
à la conception
de Noël,
la célébration
de Noël.
Car les textes
sont en train de parler
du fait
que Dieu
peut habiter
avec nous.
Et lorsque Jésus vient,
Jean chapitre 1 nous dit
que la parole
s'est faite chair
et elle a tabernaculé
entre nous.
Les langages,
c'est qu'elle a
habité entre nous.
C'est-à-dire
les Christs,
il était véritablement
ce que les temples
représentaient.
Et c'est notamment
en Christs
que nous,
l'Église,
nous pouvons trouver
ces lieux d'adoration.
Lorsque nous nous rassemblons,
les membres du corps de Christ,
les pierres vivantes
qui composent ces temples,
c'est là où nous pouvons
atteindre véritablement
la visitation des dieux,
la demeure des dieux
et la présence des dieux
perpétuellement
avec nous.
Et donc,
c'est important pour nous
de considérer
ce texte aujourd'hui
car il a des implications
très directes
pour la célébration
d'un nouvel espace,
de Noël.
Et ce sont
quelques vérités
qu'on va traiter.
Donc,
la vérité centrale
du texte,
c'est que dans un lieu
d'adoration,
l'aspiration
et les privilèges
suprêmes
du peuple des dieux
est sa merveilleuse présence.
Il faut avoir
chez toutes les personnes
qui se dirigent
envers un culte
un sens des merveilles,
un sens des privilèges,
une aspiration légitime
pour rencontrer Dieu
à cet espace.
On devrait perdre de vue,
malheureusement,
à cause de la corruption
de l'Église,
que nous sommes tout simplement
exposés aux idées personnelles
d'un homme qui vous parle.
Nous devons être conscients
qu'un lieu légitime
d'adoration
n'est pas du lieu
en soi-même,
mais c'est de la réalité
des hommes et des femmes
qui sont à la recherche
de la présence des dieux
de manière authentique
et qui ont l'attente
que Dieu nous visite
et qui cherchent
la présence des dieux
de manière convenable
à ce qui plaide Dieu.
C'est un culte
d'adoration.
L'intérêt ici
n'est pas de faire
le recherche pour savoir
quel type de discours
peut plaire aux personnes
qui nous visitent.
Les visitants,
les principaux d'entre nous,
c'est Dieu lui-même.
La personne à qui
nous cherchons
d'être agréable,
c'est Dieu lui-même.
C'est à lui
que nous voulons retrouver
à cet espace.
On n'est pas là
pour faire du massage
dans l'ego des personnes
qui viennent à l'Église.
On est là
pour plaire Dieu,
tout simplement.
Et donc,
la vérité centrale,
c'est que dans une Église
véritable,
dans un lieu
où nous attendons
voir la présence des dieux,
ce qui compte le plus,
c'est la disposition
des cœurs
de ceux qui viennent
adorer Dieu.
Pour qu'un lieu
des cultes
accomplisse
effectivement sa fonction,
il est donc essentiel
que les peuples des dieux
qui s'y rassemblent,
s'y rassemblent
avec une disposition
des cœurs
convenable
pour adorer Dieu.
Quelle est la question
clé pour nous ?
Quelle est la disposition
des cœurs
que nous devons cultiver
et quelle est la disposition
des cœurs
que nous devons préserver
afin de consacrer
cet espace
effectivement
à être
des meurs
des dieux ?
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Donc, nous allons chercher
à répondre à cette question.
La première réponse,
c'est qu'afin
de consacrer
cet espace
effectivement
à être
une habitation
des dieux,
nous devons cultiver
une disposition
de cœur
qui aspire
sa présence
de manière authentique
mais pas
superstitieuse.
C'est très important.
Quand on pense
et quand on parle
de faire une prière
des consécrations
de cet espace,
j'espère que ce qui vient
à vos esprits
ne soit pas
prendre une bouteille
d'huile
et commencer
à jeter partout
en nous attendant
de manière
très automatique
que cet espace
devienne
sacré
à cause
d'une formule
des baguettes
magiques
qu'on essaye
de faire
de manière
très ritualiste.
Et là,
je ne veux pas
critiquer forcément
l'osage
ou non
de l'huile.
On peut diverger
par rapport
à l'interprétation.
Je veux mettre
en question
l'aspect
superstitieux
de ce type
pratique.
Car il n'y a
aucune chose
qui se passe
dans la Bible
qui fonctionne
en opérant
de soi-même.
Si la disposition
du cœur
n'est pas engagée,
s'il n'y a pas
une relation réelle
lorsqu'on a
une relation
qui nous sommes là
en train de prier
Dieu
en demandant
« Voici Seigneur,
une demeure
que nous voulons
consacrer à toi »
mais que nous
ne faisons pas
l'effort
de préserver
une disposition
du cœur
constante
pour l'adorer,
qu'est-ce que
Dieu va pouvoir
dire à Israël
même dans les tabernacles
ou dans les temples
« Vos lèvres
s'approchent de moi
mais vos cœurs
sont loin. »
Et même
ces temples
qui étaient
un temple sacré
les personnes
ne pouvaient pas
s'attendre
tout simplement
à être bénies
par Dieu
jusqu'à
ils sont en train
de venir au temple.
Car dans ces passages
c'est incroyable
de remarquer
que la prière
des consécrations
de Salomon
était importante
surtout
par son contenu
que par
l'effet
d'avoir fait
une prière
de consécration.
Si je veux
que mon enfant
soit un enfant
pieux
il ne suffit
pas tout simplement
de les baptiser
des gens
aux pierres.
Si je n'élève
pas mon enfant
dans les chemins
du Seigneur
je ne peux pas
attendre
que de mettre
une étiquette
automatique
sur lui
ou de le faire
répéter une prière
puisse devenir
véritablement
la réalité
de sa piété.
Et donc ici
c'est très intéressant
de remarquer
que les temples
pourraient s'apprêter
très vite
à la superstition
et c'était le cas
à plusieurs reprises.
Mais c'est intéressant
quand on voit
les livres
de Samuel
qu'il y a eu
cet épisode
où à cause
de la corruption
surtout
des sacrificateurs
Dieu a permis
que les Philistins
volent
l'arche
de l'alliance
qui représentait
la présence
de Dieu.
Et là
il y a
ces noms
que cette femme
de sacrificateur
mort
va baptiser
son enfant
en disant
Icabod
c'est-à-dire
la gloire
de l'éternel
est partie
de la maison
de l'éternel.
Sauf que la Bible
au début
des livres
de Samuel
elle était déjà
en train de montrer
que la gloire
de Dieu
était déjà éloignée
à cause
de la corruption.
Et donc
un lieu
des cultes
ne peut pas
opérer
de soi-même.
Nous ne pouvons pas
attendre
que la présence
des dieux
soit ici toujours
ou que Dieu
soit entre nous
ou soit avec nous
si la disposition
de cœur
n'est pas celle
pour laquelle
Salomon
va prier
dans ses passages.
Donc je vous encourage
plus tard
à parcourir
tous les sujets
de prière
qu'il va toucher
mais nous pouvons lire
quelques-uns
de ces sujets
au verset 28
juste après avoir dit
les cieux des cieux
ne peuvent pas
te contenir
combien moi
cette maison
que j'ai été bâtie
et voici ce qu'il dit
ensuite
toutefois éternel
mon Dieu
sois attentive
à la prière
de ton serviteur
à sa supplication
écoute les cris
et la prière
que je t'adresse
aujourd'hui
ton serviteur
que tes yeux
soient nuit
et jour
ouverts
sur cette maison
sur les lieux
dont tu as dit
là c'est à mon nom
écoute la prière
de ton serviteur
que ton serviteur
fasse en ces lieux
deigne d'exaucer
les supplications
de ton serviteur
et de ton peuple
d'Israël
lorsqu'ils prieront
en ces lieux
exaucent du lieu
d'état des mœurs
des cieux
exaucent et pardonnent
donc qu'est-ce que
Salomon est en train
de faire
par cette prière
de consécration
il est en train
de ne rien prendre
par acquis
il est en train
de dire
Seigneur
deigne
exaucent
soit condescendant
soit miséricordieux
et à chaque fois
qu'il va développer
une bonne attente
envers la maison
de l'éternel
car il faut quand même
ne pas tomber
dans l'extrême opposé
pour nous dire
ah je dois tout simplement
prier dans ma chambre
fermer la porte
car il y a l'enseignement
du Christ
qui va dans sa direction
mais c'est pour confronter
l'hypocrisie religieuse
de ceux qui traitaient
de manière superstitieuse
les temples
par contre
les lieux d'adoration
les lieux des rencontres
avec Dieu
et la persévérance
dans les prières communautaires
c'est un principe
qui doit être toujours là
donc les lieux d'adoration
de rassemblement public
il est un lieu particulier
où Dieu
s'est plaît
de répondre
d'une manière
un peu plus spéciale
c'est faire un peu plus présent
être plus favorable
donc d'aller
à une église légitime
à un lieu
des rassemblements
ou des réunions communautaires
c'est une manière
légitime et biblique
d'avoir des bonnes attentes
envers la rencontre
avec Dieu
et les bénédictions
qui viennent avec ça
et voilà pourquoi
Salomon
il va parler par exemple
des plusieurs bénédictions
que nous pouvons retrouver
à l'église
il va dire
quand les personnes
viennent prier
et à cause de leurs péchés
ils sont en train
d'expérimenter de la maladie
de la plaie
des catastrophes
ou les situations
où les étrangers
sont sous oppression
ou pour que toutes les nations
connaissent
à chaque fois
vous avez remarqué
dans cette prière
qu'il prie
en prenant en considération
que toutes ces difficultés
qu'on traverse
sont liées
quelque part
à nos péchés
et à la fin
il va porter une bénédiction
je vous lis
de verset 55
jusqu'au verset 61
où
par sa bénédiction
verset 67
il dit
que l'éternel
notre Dieu
soit avec nous
comme il a été
avec nos pères
qui nous les abandonne
point
et nous délaisse
mais qui l'incline
nos cœurs
vers lui
afin que nous marchions
dans toutes ses voies
et que nous observions
ses commandements
ses lois
et ses ordonnances
qu'il a prescrits
à nos pères
que ses paroles
l'objet
de mes supplications
devant Dieu
devant l'éternel
soit jour et nuit
présent à l'éternel
notre Dieu
et qu'il fasse en tout temps
droit à son serviteur
et à son peuple
afin que tous les peuples
de la terre
connaissent que l'éternel
est Dieu
et qu'il n'y a point d'autre
que votre cœur
soit tout à l'éternel
notre Dieu
comme il est aujourd'hui
pour suivre ses lois
et pour observer
ses commandements
quelle est la leçon ici ?
ce n'est pas
la prière
des consécrations
qui consacre
quand il y a l'éternel
c'est les contenus
de cette prière
et qui selon Salomon
doit être perpétuel
si le peuple
n'est pas résolu
à marcher dans ses voies
si le peuple
qui vient à l'église
à l'attente
de certaines bénédictions
sache que la première bénédiction
est celle
qui peut assurer
toutes les autres
c'est la présence
de Dieu
Dieu
elle est bien
suprême
je vais à l'église
me rencontrer
avec Dieu
je ne le vois pas
de manière ritualiste
pour essayer
d'apaiser ma conscience
de faire un peu
les contrepoids
dans la balance
par rapport
à mes péchés
pendant la semaine
je viens chercher
du pardon
oui
mais je viens
dans l'attente
de me rencontrer
avec Dieu
les biens suprêmes
et en me retrouvant
dans la présence
de Dieu
avec une disposition
de cœur correcte
en répentance
et diligence
pour me sanctifier
cet environnement
du culte
sera agréable à Dieu
l'environnement
du culte
agréable à Dieu
c'est un environnement
marqué par un désir
sincère
de retrouver Dieu
et une manière
de chercher Dieu
qui honore les désirs
qui nous visitent
car si Dieu
est là
et nous voulons
que Dieu soit là
nous devons le chercher
par les voies
de la sanctification
et donc
que cette disposition
de cœur
de tout cœur
envers Dieu
soit la marque
de notre église
pour qu'on n'ait pas
un rapport
superstitieux
envers un endroit
d'adoration
le deuxième point
c'est qu'à fond
de consacrer
cet espace
effectivement
à la demeure
des dieux
nous devons cultiver
une disposition
de cœur
soumise
et accuyante
de sa parole
donc
nous avons lu
le verset 10
mais nous aurons pu
commencer
à partir
du verset 9
je pense
donc là
il y a eu
toutes les prescriptions
qui Dieu avait données
donc attention
Dieu
nous dépendons
des dieux
non seulement
pour qu'il nous révèle
qui il est
car à cause
de notre corruption
nous pouvons
même utilisant
les noms des dieux
et du Christ
créer des idoles
il ne suffit pas
de dire
je crois à Jésus Christ
et lorsqu'on va
décrire Jésus Christ
on donne une description
complètement différente
de ce qu'il y a
les Christ bibliques
le seul Jésus
qui sauve
est le Jésus
de la Bible
des biographies
qui ont été rédigées
inspirées par Dieu
pour qu'on soit sûr
qui est le vrai Christ
les vrais Christ
qui sauvent
et donc Dieu
non seulement
il doit nous communiquer
qui il est
pour qu'on puisse nettoyer
nos mauvaises conceptions
des dieux
nos conceptions des dieux
qui sont tachées
par nos péchés
ou par nos désirs
parfois très charnels
et donc
des fois
on entend parler aujourd'hui
non je trouve
que ton Dieu
il est très sévère
et ce n'est pas question
d'être mon Dieu
ou ton Dieu
c'est question d'être
le seul vrai Dieu
tel qu'il se révèle
dans sa parole
et donc
les dieux
qui doivent être sévères
au quai
par rapport
au péché
à la corruption humaine
il est en même temps
si généreux
car c'est lui-même
qui pourvoit
les moyens
pour satisfaire
les démons
de sa justice
et donc Dieu
il doit être là
non seulement pour nous dire
qui il est
c'est révélé à nous
mais Dieu
il nous donne aussi
des consignes
des prescriptions
des règles
pour nous enseigner
comment nous devons
l'adorer
donc toute la construction
du temple
dans tous les détails
bien sûr
on n'a plus besoin
de suivre
ces formules
car il était en train
de pointer
dans tous ses aspects
envers Christ
qui viendrait
donc Christ
il est
les temples parfaits
voilà pourquoi il dit
détruisez les temples
en trois jours
je les rébattis
et la Bible dit
il parlait
de son corps
car
c'est ce que Jésus
a fait
il a accompli
la signification
suprême
du temple
les temples
n'a plus besoin
d'exister
et il dit
il pointe envers lui
voilà c'est accompli
vous allez détruire
ces temples
ces corps
et en trois jours
je les rébattis
il n'a pas rébattis
les temples
mais il a ressuscité
au troisième jour
et donc c'est Christ lui-même
qui est l'habitation
des dieux
entre nous
en forme corporelle
humaine
mais c'est important
de remarquer
que toutes les prescriptions
de l'Ancien Testament
par rapport à la construction
du temple
c'était des prescriptions
qui pointaient
envers Christ
et nous devrions respecter
quelle est la leçon
c'est que la manière
dont on adore Dieu
est la manière
prescrite par Dieu
nous n'avons pas
toute cette liberté
qu'on pense pouvoir avoir
et attendre
qu'en sortant
des principes bibliques
des choses qui doivent
se passer dans un culte
on puisse compter toujours
avec la présence de Dieu
pourquoi on a
dépensé tellement d'argent
tellement d'énergie
tellement d'efforts
et nous ne voyons pas
clairement les évidences
des transformations
chez les personnes
dans plusieurs églises
de nos jours
c'est car
on a devenu
un système
on a devenu un système
qui a cherché
à attirer les personnes
par les divertissements
on fait des efforts
pour insérer
dans un culte
des pièces de théâtre
des danses
et plusieurs types
de choses
pour divertir les personnes
chaque fois
on a moins le temps
pour prier
conforme à la parole
et pour étudier
la parole de Dieu
nous ne sommes pas
en train de conduire
nos cultes
de manière agréable
à Dieu
telle qu'il est prescrite
pour Dieu
comment Paul écrit
à Timothée
il dit
j'ai écrit ces choses
pour que dans mon absence
tu saches
comment procéder
dans la maison des dieux
la maison de Dieu vivant
colonne et appuie la vérité
c'est pas à nous
d'inventer
les manières
la Bible elle est claire
le nouveau testament
elle est claire
quels sont les éléments
qui doivent composer
un culte public
quels sont les éléments
qui en composant
un culte public
Dieu s'est plaire
les visiter
les demeurer
entre nous
si nous disons
que l'espace d'adoration
est la maison
de Dieu vivant
Dieu a du zèle
envers cet espace
et c'est inconformé
à sa parole
que nous allons les vivre
donc
toutes ces prescriptions
pour les temples
elles étaient importantes
pour les tabernacles
etc
mais c'était encore
plus intéressant
de remarquer
que l'arche
de l'alliance
qui était la représentation
principale
de la présence
des dieux
au temple
vous vous rappelez bien
à Trion
comme si on grand jardin
à l'extérieur
du temple
ensuite
on rentre dans les temples
il y a les 100 lieux
un lieu un peu plus sacré
et ensuite
les 100 des 100
ok
et une fois seul
par an
les suprêmes
sacrificateurs
pourraient rentrer
en représentant
l'expiation
du péché
de tous les peuples
donc c'était
l'accès
à la présence
des dieux
marqué
par toutes ces étapes
des sanctifications
et des respects
à la parole
de Dieu
mais quel était
l'élément central
à l'intérieur
de l'arche
verset 9
il n'y avait
dans l'arche
que les deux tables
de pierre
que Moïse déposa
en oreille
ces tables de pierre
représentent
la parole de Dieu
les dix commandements
l'alliance des dieux
avec les peuples
vous vous rappelez bien
les contextes
où Dieu a parlé
à Moïse
pour donner les tables
c'est intéressant
Dieu a visité
la montagne
comme une nouée
avec tonnerre
une nouée épaisse
une nouée
qui représentait
l'approche
de la présence
des dieux
mais au même temps
une nouée
complètement dense
obscure
c'était un scénario
très effrayant
la montagne
elle était en flamme
c'était comme si
Dieu était en train
de dire à l'humanité
vous adorez
les païens
plusieurs divinités
fausses
certains qui contrôlent
les feux
d'autres contrôlent
la pluie
la terre
etc
Dieu il est en train
de faire de manière
chirurgicale
la manifestation
de sa présence
en contrôlant
de manière chirurgicale
chacun de ses éléments
pour dire
moi je suis les dieux
au-dessus de tout autre dieu
le seul vrai dieu
et je descends
et le plus dieu est proche
le plus éloigné
il nous semble
le plus mystérieux
le plus inextrutable
il est
et c'est intéressant
car il y avait
les tremblements de terre
il y avait les tonnerres
il y avait les feux
sauf que la Bible a dit
que les peuples
n'ont qu'ils tremblaient
vraiment
lorsqu'il dieu
a parlé
dieu
s'est fait
surtout présent
par sa parole
et voilà pourquoi
quand on pense à Noël
qu'est-ce que Jean
va nous dire
et la parole
s'est fait chair
et elle habitait
parmi nous
donc pour ceux
qui vont
à l'église
dans l'attente
de rencontrer
dieu
ils doivent
aller à l'église
avec une disposition
des coeurs
désireuse
d'accueillir
la parole
de Dieu
de se laisser
confronter
par la parole
de Dieu
d'être visité
par Dieu
à travers sa parole
pourquoi
car Dieu
a créé
tout l'univers
par sa parole
puissante
et Christ
nous est présenté
comme celui
qui soutient
tout l'univers
par sa parole
puissante
et donc
comment Dieu
a créé l'univers
par sa parole
comment Dieu
se présente
surtout à l'humanité
par sa parole
comment la Bible
nous enseigne
que nous sommes
récréés
par la prédication
de la parole
la vallée des os
desséchés
aucun espoir
pour les saluts
de l'humanité
aucune stratégie humaine
aucune augmentation
philosophique
par contre
lorsque nous prononçons
la parole de Dieu
en conformité
avec la parole
de Dieu
la Bible
les saints esprits
apportent cette vie
c'est la parole
qu'on appelle
fiat
c'est cette parole
créatrice
c'est un décret
de la part des dieux
et donc voilà pourquoi
Jean va nous présenter
au commencement
il était les verbes
ou logos
ça veut dire
non seulement
la parole
mais l'essence
de l'existence
même
c'était une conception
philosophique
qui voulait
porter la vérité
expliquer la vie
et tout rassembler
dans l'unité
de ce qui peut donner
de la signification
du sens
donc c'est
Christ lui-même
qui est la parole
la raison d'être
de l'humanité
nous avons été créés
à l'image des dieux
à l'image du Christ
et donc il était
le logos
et le logos
a tabernaculé
entre nous
voilà
Noël
c'est la parole
qui s'est fait chair
c'est cette parole
par laquelle
Dieu nous a donné
tellement d'informations
à propos de lui-même
et maintenant
nous pouvons voir
la parole vivante
dans la personne
de son Jésus Christ
et voilà pourquoi
les centres de la parole
des dieux
la Bible
c'est d'étudier
surtout
Christ comme accomplissement
de la parole
et Christ en enseignant
lui-même
la parole des dieux
Amen
et donc il faut qu'on aille
si nous voulons
que cette demeure
soit préservée
comme une demeure
pour Dieu
en coeur
prédisposé
à accueillir
et se soumettre
à la parole
afin de consacrer
cet espace
troisième point
effectivement
à la demeure
de Dieu
nous devons avoir
une disposition
des coeurs
remplie
des convictions
que Dieu
demeure avec nous
et ici
c'est tout simplement
avoir
une expérience
effective
avec les faits
ici
les passages
il dit au verset 10
au moment
où les sacrificateurs
sortirent du lieu
sans
la nouée
remplit
la maison
de l'éternel
et les sacrificateurs
ne purent pas
y rester
pour faire
les services
donc ici
nous sommes devant
en fait
car lorsque
au verset 27
Salomon va dire
mais quoi
Dieu
habitera-t-il
véritablement
sur terre
ici
c'est pas pour exprimer
un doute
car les faits
viennent de se passer
il est en train
d'exprimer
plutôt
en sens
de merveille
d'étonnement
vous comprenez
il n'est pas
en train de douter
du fait
on devrait douter
c'est légitime
de douter
dans un certain sens
que
Dieu puisse
se plaire
ou nous donner
cette grâce
de demeurer
avec nous
par contre
les faits
que Dieu
nous a visités
les faits
que Dieu
a visités
les temples
étaient quelque chose
de déjà constaté
de déjà
expérimenté
et donc
qu'est-ce qui donne
du sens
à un lieu du culte
c'est
à nouveau
la prédisposition
des cœurs
des personnes
qui composent
l'église
et qui sont
les personnes
qui composent
l'église
ce sont des personnes
qui ont déjà
expérimenté
de manière
véritable
et de premièrement
la visitation
de Dieu
et cela a lieu
au moment
où nous expérimentons
notre conversion
car il n'y a pas
de conversion
si on n'a pas été
visité par Dieu
la foi
de mes parents
ne peut pas
nous sauver
car Dieu n'a pas
des petits-fils
ni des nouveaux
Dieu a
des enfants
et donc
il faut que la relation
de chaque personne
avec Dieu
soit en relation
des premièrement
nous sommes témoins
du Christ
et donc la réalité
c'est que
si mon expérience
avec l'église
c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'expérience
du nominalisme
c'est-à-dire
c'est l'habitude
ou la tradition
de la famille
d'aller à l'église
sauf que les temples
il est déjà vide
de la gloire de Dieu
et je ne trouve pas
dans certaines églises
la majorité
de personnes
qui soient
véritablement
des personnes
qui mènent
une relation
avec Dieu
constamment
on ne peut pas
attendre
que dans un environnement
dans une ambiance
où nous ne sommes pas
devant des pierres vivantes
le rassemblement
ne peut pas former
un temple
pour l'habitation
de son esprit
donc quel est
le point ici
c'est que
l'église
qui attend
expérimenter
la présence
des dieux
c'est l'église
qui a déjà
expérimenté
la présence
des dieux
ce sont ceux
qui ne doutent pas
du fait
et la réalité
c'est qu'il est fait
il est là
et c'est par
ces moyens
que les personnes
trouvent la vraie conversion
quels moyens
lorsque la communauté
qui accueille
la présence
des dieux
est une communauté
où nous constatons
l'authenticité
de leur relation
avec Dieu
les personnes
nous visitent
et elles n'arrivent pas
à expliquer
le l'église
il donne cet exemple
il dit
il y avait une femme
qui était adepte
de l'espiritisme
et qui a visité
l'église
et plus tard
elle la laisse convertir
mais dans sa première
expérience
elle est venue
vers les pasteurs
pour dire
c'est intéressant
car
j'ai ressenti
par votre culte
d'adoration
une présence
similaire
à cette présence
spirituelle
que j'ai ressent
dans les cercles
de ma religion
sauf que là
c'est une sensation
d'oppression
et ici
c'est plutôt
une sensation
de paix
et de joie
la présence
de Dieu
entre nous
elle est perceptible
lorsque
les croyants
qui composent
une église
sont véritablement
en pleine conviction
que lorsqu'ils marchent
envers l'église
ils ont ces sens
de transcendance
ces sens
de révérence
les sens
qui Dieu
nous visite
c'est un point
des rencontres
avec Dieu
tous les dimanches
où nous pouvons avoir
l'assurance
que Dieu
ne va jamais manquer
si cette église
est authentique
donc ces faits
elles sont les faits
dont nous devrions
nous approprier
car les faits
il est là
et nous ne pouvons pas douter
quel est les faits
les faits
c'est que
lorsqu'il est peuple
à obéir Dieu
pour inaugurer
les tabernacles
et les temples
pardon
les temples ici
la nouée
est descendue
Dieu s'est fait présent
Dieu a honoré
sa promesse
la prière
de Salomon
c'est Seigneur
qu'on garde
sa disposition
de coeur
pour toujours
car on a déjà
expérimenté
on ne veut pas perdre
on veut que tu sois là
pour toujours avec nous
par contre
c'est
ce n'était
qu'il
et pour plus
que les hommes
n'ont pas pu
se tenir debout
par la présence
de la gloire
de Dieu
de la chékenade
c'était très faible
par rapport
à la réalité
du fait
qu'un jour
Dieu
non seulement
est descendu
pour être
confiné
dans un temple
ou dans une arche
imaginez
les dieux
dans sa grandeur
en se confinant
à un temple
et c'était un temple
très grand
par contre
lorsqu'il l'accomplisse
ce n'était pas
qu'une apparence
de Dieu
donc la nouée
c'était pour représenter
la visitation
de Dieu
mais c'était
une apparence
de Dieu
elle ne pourrait pas
représenter
Dieu lui-même
sauf qu'à Noël
nous sommes devant
l'effet
des faits
nous ne sommes pas
devant
des illusions
fantasieuses
nous ne pouvons pas
permettre
que Noël
devienne pour nous
comme il est
devenu
pour
la tradition
catholique
et nous ne pouvons
pas non plus
mépriser
la célébration
de cette date
même si on sait
que Jésus
le plus probablement
n'est pas né
effectivement
le 25 décembre
et par contre
même dans la parole
de Dieu
nous voyons par exemple
Pierre dire
qu'il était conscient
qu'il allait mourir
bientôt
mais il n'allait pas
laisser de répéter
l'avènement
1er Timothée 3
lorsque Paul
va dire
la colonne
est l'appui
de la vérité
et voici
grand
est le mystère
et là
il va citer
les faits
de Noël
l'incarnation
de Christ
la contemplation
des anges
nous ne pouvons
pas permettre
que la manière
superficielle
dont Noël
est traité
aujourd'hui
avec les sentiments
un esprit
flux
des générosités
et des paix
enlève
la réalité
du fait
et c'est
l'effet
des faits
c'est l'effet
le plus soucrème
qui a eu lieu
c'est un Dieu
dont les cieux
les cieux bleus
que vous voyez
ne peuvent pas
contenir
les cieux des cieux
ne peuvent pas
contenir
car la Bible
nous présente
cet univers
pas comme
en étant
héliocentrique
autour du soleil
mais Christ
est centrique
au trône
suprême
des dieux
rien ne peut
contenir
la présence
et la gloire
des dieux
mais par contre
la Bible nous dit
qu'effectivement
dans la condescendance
c'est Dieu la deuxième
personne de la Trinité
Dieu les fils
il s'est confiné
à un embryon
dans les ventres
d'une femme
vierge
et si nous doutons
de n'importe quel
fait
de l'évangile
il n'y a pas de salut
pour nous
il n'y a pas
Dieu avec nous
et donc l'effet
c'est que Dieu
dans sa condescendance
il est venu
habiter
de manière
condescendante
condensée
si vous voulez
et qu'il habitait
véritablement
dans un homme
qui était un enfant
qui a vécu
la vie d'un être mort
et donc
la gloire
des dieux
voilée
mais en même temps
la grâce
de pouvoir
contempler Dieu
dans la manière
dont cet homme
a vécu
et dont cet homme
nous a parlé
et enseigné
donc l'effet
il est là
la question pour nous
c'est
est-ce qu'on va
s'approprier du fait
Dieu a visité
l'humanité
l'histoire
est divisée
entre avant Jésus
et après Jésus
Christ
voici ce qu'il dit
Pierre
dans sa deuxième lettre
car je sais
que ma mort
est proche
selon la promesse
que nous avons
de notre Seigneur
Jésus Christ
et je ferai tout
mon possible
pour qu'après mon départ
vous puissiez toujours
avoir un souvenir
de ces choses
car nous
attention
nous
vous avons
fait connaître
la puissance
et la venue
de notre Seigneur
Jésus Christ
non en suivant
des fables
habilement inventées
mais comme nous l'avons
vu
de nos propres yeux
ce ne sont pas
des fables
nous avons vu
de nos propres yeux
la Vierge enceinte
avec cette
œuvre de Saint-Esprit
pour
pour que Dieu
soit
engendré
dans un ventre humain
l'étoile
qui a conduit
les anges
qui ont fait
chanter
les magnificats
ce ne sont pas
des fables
et qu'est-ce qu'il dit
habilement inventées
mais comme nous l'avons vu
de nos propres yeux
car il a reçu
des dieux
les pères
l'honneur
et la gloire
lorsqu'une voix
lui fit
entendre
du ciel
ses paroles
c'est lui
mon fils
bien aimé
en qui j'ai mis
toute mon affection
et nous avons
entendu cette voix
venant du ciel
lorsque nous étions
avec lui
sur la montagne
c'est la montagne
de la transfiguration
c'était un fait
observable
audible
que ces hommes
qui étaient des témoins
oculaires
étaient en train
de les constater
et c'est 19
et nous avons
la parole des prophètes
à laquelle vous ferez bien
le prêter attention
comme à une lampe
qui brille
dans un lieu
obscur
jusqu'à ce que
les jours s'élèvent
et que l'étoile
du matin
s'élève
dans vos cœurs
donc quel est
l'objectif
c'est que
l'effet
il est là
comme opportunité
pour tous
mais aussi
par rapport
auquel
si nous rejetons
c'est pour la condamnation
de tous
il y a une lumière
qui a éclaté
et qui a bré
Dieu s'est fait chair
il a habité entre nous
et Dieu
l'a exposé
l'opportunité
des rédemptions
des réconciliations
avec Dieu
Dieu avec nous
non seulement
pour qu'on les contemple
dès loin
mais Dieu avec nous
pour nous réconcilier
avec lui
l'histoire est divisée
par cette emphase
et la croix
était
une crucifixion
publique
une exposition
pour que Dieu
affiche
de manière
la plus ouverte
que possible
son moyen
de réconciliation
Dieu avec nous
Dieu révélé
dans sa gloire
par son humiliation
par son humilité
par sa condescendance
envers nous
et qu'est-ce qu'on espère
à partir de là
l'effet
il est là
l'effet proclamé
maintenant
à vous
les soupliers
Dieu
qui non seulement
cette lumière
brille à l'extérieur
de vous
mais qui cette étoile
du matin
qui est appelée
les Christs
la parole
une lampe
qui brille
qui pointe
envers Christ
qui présente
Christ
et au-dedans
de nous
que l'étoile
du matin
s'élève
dans vos cœurs
donc
l'église
est une communauté
qui se dirige
à un sanctuaire
avec la certitude
et la confiance
du fait
que Dieu
a habité avec nous
et qu'il habite
avec nous
qu'il demeure
il faut qu'on vienne
avec une disposition
de cœur confiante
et le dernier point
c'est qu'avant
de consacrer
cet espace
effectivement
à la demeure
des dieux
nous devons cultiver
une disposition
de cœur
remplie
dans le sens
des merveilles
du fait
que Dieu
demeure avec nous
on ne peut jamais
prendre par acquis
le fait
que Dieu
peut nous visiter
qu'il nous a visités
donc
on revient
au verset 27
mais quoi
Dieu
habiterait-il
véritablement
sur terre
et d'où vient
ces sens des merveilles
et à partir du moment
où ces sens des merveilles
est cautérisé
dans nos vies
dans la collectivité
d'une église
à partir du moment
où la liturgie
la direction du culte
l'organisation
des ministères
nous donne la sensation
que les choses
peuvent marcher
de manière automatique
hyper organisée
quelqu'un a déjà dit
même si un pasteur
continue d'utiliser
les mêmes mots
que dans le passé
il était plutôt marqué
par la puissance
des dieux
il peut utiliser
les mêmes sermons
avec les mêmes mots
mais toute la communauté
peut noter
que l'onction
n'est plus là
peut noter
que s'il n'est pas à jour
avec ses disciplines
spirituelles
son intégrité morale
sa piété
sa pureté
sa sainteté
c'est évident
pour tous
que la puissance
n'est plus là
on a plus la sensation
de rhétorique
de dramaturgie
qu'il y a d'authenticité
qu'il y a d'autorité
venant des dieux
et donc si
l'église
perd
les sens
des merveilles
elle risque
soit
d'être lourdement
corrigée par Dieu
et ça c'est la meilleure
des options
comme c'était le cas
d'Anania et Safira
ou Akan
qui a caché cette cape
car nous supplions
comme Salomon a supplé
que si
l'impureté
entre nous
n'est pas découverte
et corrigée
que la main
des dieux
puisse pèser
lourdement
entre nous
afin de
préserver
cet espace
comme un espace
qui est
source
de vie
un espace
qui est
présence
des dieux
et d'où vient
ces sens
des merveilles
il y a au moins
trois aspects
très clairs
dans ces passages
le premier
c'est la distance
entre créateur
et créature
lorsqu'il dit
la grandeur des dieux
voici les cieux
des cieux
ne peuvent te contenir
combien moi
cette maison
que j'ai bâtie
donc
et à plusieurs reprises
dans sa prière
il va dire
réponds du lieu
de ta demeure
donc même s'il est
en train de dire
que cet espace
soit un lieu
d'habitation perpétuelle
il est conscient
Salomon
que les lieux
particuliers
que Dieu a choisis
pour être
les trônes de l'univers
et les cieux
des cieux
ok
donc Dieu
il est omniprésent
il y a un parc
des mystères ici
mais Dieu
dans sa communication
avec l'humanité
il y a une distance
infinie
entre créateur
et créature
et son lieu
particulier
d'habitation
c'est son trône
céleste
vous êtes avec moi
par contre
Dieu a toujours
donné les privilèges
à l'humanité
depuis la création
d'Adenaïe
de sortir l'homme
de la poussière
et l'insérer
dans un sanctuaire
en lieu
des rencontres
entre Dieu
et l'homme
ce qui est intéressant
à remarquer
c'est que
la présence
de Dieu
avec nous
n'est jamais prise
pour acquis
et donc
les cieux des cieux
ne peuvent pas
te contenir
c'est un rappel
qu'avant même
qu'on parle
de problème
de péché
au moins
immédiatement
chez nous
chez nos cœurs
je me rappelle
avant ma conversion
je n'osais pas
m'approcher
de l'église
c'est pas forcément
quand je pensais
que l'église
était mauvaise
même s'il y avait
beaucoup de scandales
liés à l'église
au Brésil
mais c'était surtout
une idée
de ne pas pouvoir
m'approcher
de quelque chose
pourquoi je n'étais pas prêt
je n'étais pas digne
donc parfois
les personnes
ne se donnent
même pas
les privilèges
d'entendre
les bonnes nouvelles
car ils pensent
que de s'approcher
de Dieu
c'est de s'exposer
à un jugement
à un réger
mais ça c'est la réalité
pour nous tous
car nous sommes tous
condamnés à causer
nos péchés
mais avant même
de parler des péchés
considérons
que même les êtres
qui ont été créés
pour être les plus proches
de Dieu
les anges célestes
ils n'avaient pas
l'accès
pour on dire
sans réserve
à la présence
de Dieu
irrestrict
si vous voulez
il y a un ange
qui était le plus important
d'entre tous
notamment Satan
qui a échoué
qui avait été créé
avec la capacité
les plus vélèges
d'être les plus proches
de la présence
de Dieu
il était appelé
les chérubans
de la garde
pourquoi ?
qu'est-ce qu'il gardait ?
comme l'arche de l'alliance
les chérubans
qui ont les ailes
sur l'arche
pour nous protéger
de contempler
la gloire
des dieux directement
mais les anges
même
les chérubans
ils ont des ailes
pour couvrir
leur visage
car Dieu
en tant que créateur
il est si sublime
il habite dans
une lumière
tellement inaccessible
que sa pureté
son éclat
l'éclat
de sa beauté
empêche
les moindres proches
de n'importe quelle créature
pour plus sainte
qu'elle soit
moralement
de sa présence
voilà pourquoi
le soleil
est une bonne
illustration
utilisée par Dieu
aucun élément
de la création
ne peut s'approcher
du soleil
s'il n'est pas
lumière
car il sera
pulvérisé
donc indépendamment
du problème
de péché
aucun
n'être humain
aucune créature
ne peut s'approcher
de Dieu
car nous voyons
l'immensité
de Dieu
la grandeur
la beauté
de Dieu
cette lumière
inaccessible
et donc
quoi ?
est-ce que Dieu
ferait sa demeure
sur terre ?
vous voyez
les sens des merveilles
même si le péché
n'était pas là
et lorsque Jésus
vient
c'est ces mêmes
dieux
c'est l'étoile
du matin
c'est ces
Christ
qui s'est vidé
pour entendre
sa gloire
donc remarquez bien
cette semaine
je suis encore
avec les symptômes
de l'influenza
donc un type
de grippe très fort
pire que la Covid
et je ne sais pas
si vous avez déjà remarqué
les femmes
elles souffrent beaucoup
quand elles sont enceintes
et surtout
quand elles accouchent
mais pour ceux
qui disent
qu'elles souffrent
plus que les hommes
c'est qu'elles n'ont
jamais vu un homme
avec la grippe
je plaisante
mais c'est intéressant
car
ce mystère
il est très intéressant
donc on voit
un Christ
qui
dans son humilité
pour nous sauver
bien sûr
il va se voiler
de la chair humaine
et danser
qui pourrait être
représenté par notre attente
voilà pourquoi
les régés
de la majorité
des juifs
donc les fils
des dieux
ou les messies
envoyés des dieux
ils ne pourraient pas
souffrir ce qu'il a souffert
comment
pourrait-il
être né
dans un stable
dans un mangeoir
vous comprenez
donc nous voyons
cette manière
d'Octrice
se vider
de l'apparence
de sa gloire
Philippien
il nous explique ça
il n'a pas
laissé
d'être
Dieu
car en lui
habitait
corporellement
toute la plénitude
de la divinité
ok
Dieu
des dieux
avec nous
mais
il a dû
s'abstenir
des prérogatives
de sa gloire
de ses puissances
donc pourquoi
je parlais
de la grille
car
rien que
de perdre
un peu
de nos faibles
puissances
nous décourage
énormément
imaginons
Christ
lorsqu'il
était
craché
frappé
battu
et volontairement
il n'a jamais
laissé d'être Dieu
à n'importe quel moment
il aurait pu
avec les souffles
de ses narines
détruire
tous ses ennemis
mais volontairement
il s'est voilé
il a renoncé
temporairement
pourquoi
et là on fait
la transition
vers la prochaine distance
c'est
la distance
spirituelle
donc Jésus
il est venu
non seulement
pour qu'on ait accès
à la contemplation
des dieux
en chair
la révélation
glorieuse
des dieux
avec nous
la didatique
des dieux
est incroyable
un plan
qui nous permet
de connaître
encore plus
dieux
de la manière
la plus accessible
pour nous
car il s'est fait
homme
et nous pouvons
comprendre mieux
ce qu'il y a un homme
mais l'objectif
des dieux
c'est pas tout simplement
contempler
ma gloire
à Jésus
c'est
réconcilier
vous avec moi
ayez accès
à moi
en Jésus
soyez
trouvés
en Jésus
et voilà
la deuxième distance
c'est la distance
spirituelle
ces passages
à plusieurs reprises
réveillant
sur la question
du péché
à cause de leur péché
toute bénédiction
qu'on souplit à Dieu
en assimilant
nos péchés
mais surtout
!
surtout
désirant
la présence
des dieux
continuellement
avec nous
et donc
dieux dans sa beauté
positivement pur
inaccessible
créateur
ok?
si
nous pourrions
imaginer
et nous approcher
de lui
rien qui est par créature
même si sans
pas possible
par contre
encore
un filment plus
impossible
à cause de notre impureté
car la nature
des dieux
elle est pure
elle est qualitativement
pure
c'est-à-dire
s'approcher plus
au moins des dieux
n'est pas quantitatif
car nous ne sommes pas
en train de nous comparer
avec nos prochains
pour savoir
qui est plus pécheur
que l'autre
les péchés
il est mesuré
par rapport
à contre
qui nous péchons
donc c'est-à-dire
si je pêche
contre ma mère
c'est plus abominable
pourquoi?
car c'est la personne
qui m'aime le plus
elle est la plus digne
de mon obéissance
de mon honneur
si je pêche
contre un juge
il y a la question
d'autorité
donc les transgressions
seront encore plus
considérées
comme
dignes
d'une punition
sévère
Dieu
il est à la une
c'est pas ça
l'expression
Dieu est
en même temps
à la fois
merci
l'autorité
suprême
car créateur
de toutes les choses
source
ultime
de toute moralité
juge
suprême
et donc
les moindres péchés
commis
contre lui
c'est déjà
digne
d'une punition
infinie
voilà pourquoi
l'enfer
est la seule
réponse adaptée
à ce qui mérite
n'importe quel être
mort
dans sa transgression
car c'est impossible
d'avoir accès à Dieu
si nous avons commis
les moindres péchés
contre un être
qui qualitativement
est pur
positivement
est sans
c'est une question
des natures divines
s'il peut
assimiler
les moindres péchés
la moindre tâche
il n'y a plus Dieu
car c'est nécessaire
à la nature des dieux
qu'il soit absolument
pur et sans
et donc
l'enfer
est la seule réponse
juste appropriée
aux moindres péchés
devant l'autorité
des dieux
par contre
quand on pense
à la dignité
des dieux
un dieu
qui nous a
tout donné
sans qu'on aille
les moindres mérites
qui nous a créés
à partir d'une poussière
pour nous donner accès
à toutes les bonnes choses
de ces mondes
qu'il a créées
pour que toutes ces bonnes choses
soient des moyens
pour réjouir
et constater
un être
encore plus
glorieux
que les choses bonnes
qu'on réjouit dans cette vie
donc toutes les empreintes
des dieux
dans les bonnes choses
de la vie
comptent envers Dieu
comme bien suprême
un dieu d'amour
un dieu qui n'a pas
épargné son fils
pour nous
et donc quand on pense
que les péchés commis
contre Dieu
c'est infiniment pire
que péché contre ma mère
contre la personne
qui mène les plus
car il est digne
de tout l'amour
il est totalement aimable
et notamment
Christ en venant
il est
attention
il manque des goûts
pour les bonnes choses
moi je n'avais pas
été habitué
par exemple
avec les fromages
français
ou les vents
je ne sais même pas
discerner bien les choses
mais même pour
des bonnes musiques
on nous dit
qu'il faut
cultiver un goût
pour pouvoir
apprendre à apprécier
les bonnes choses
et malheureusement
on a perdu
les goûts pour Dieu
on est tellement
accroché au péché
qu'on n'arrive même
pas à apprécier
qu'est-ce qui détermine
l'amabilité des choses
donc bien sûr
c'est perfection
ok
donc Dieu
est beauté
suprême
dans tous ses attributs
il est généreux
il est miséricordieux
il est compatissant
à l'extrême
à l'infini
donc il est digne
de toute amabilité
il exige de nous
de vivre
la belle vie
qui Christ a vécu
c'est impossible
de prendre les dix commandements
on peut chercher
à nous défendre
car on sait
qu'on n'arrive pas
à accomplir
et voilà pourquoi
on essaie de s'opposer
quand on est tellement
aditique des péchés
qu'on veut plutôt
supprimer la culpabilité
de la conscience
mais la réalité
c'est que tous les êtres humains
ont la capacité
de contempler
les dix commandements
et se dire
c'est une vie belle
j'aurais aimé
pouvoir vivre cette vie
mais la Bible
elle décrit
que Christ
est l'objet suprême
du plaisir de Dieu
donc si quelqu'un
a un goût
suprême
c'est Dieu
voici mon fils
bien aimé
en qui j'ai mis
toute mon affection
si moi
je n'ai pas affection
pour Christ
c'est un problème
grave au-des-en-de-moi
car en Christ
nous trouvons
des motivations
pour satisfaire
totalement
l'amour des dieux
la joie des dieux
la réjouissance
des dieux
et la Bible
nous présente Christ
comme les choisis
ou les distingués
d'entre des milliers
elle nous présente Christ
comme l'objet
suprême
d'adoration
de tous les anges
et c'est ce Christ
là
qui est venu
pour régler
la problématique
de péché
avec nous
donc quand on considère
la distance
de la création
et qu'on considère
la distance morale
on est davantage
convaincu
de la nécessité
de l'orêt
donc pourquoi
Jésus Christ
a dû venir
en tant qu'être humain
non seulement
pour qu'on ait accès
à la contemplation
des dieux
mais pour vivre
en tant qu'être humain
une vie parfaite
à notre place
pour vivre
cette vie d'amour
que Dieu vit
qu'on n'arrive pas à vivre
et pour souffrir
à la croix
la punition
qu'on méritait
pour qu'on puisse
se présenter à Dieu
avoir accès à Dieu
il est les sacrifices
parfaits
nous nous présentons
devant Dieu
en disant
voici Noël
Dieu avec nous
nous présentons
nos mains vides
pour recevoir
des dieux
les seuls sacrifices
capables
de satisfaire
les justes exigences
c'est Dieu lui-même
car il sait
que personne ne peut
jamais satisfaire
les exigences
des dieux
pour la réconciliation
c'est Dieu lui-même
qui nous offre
les seuls sacrifices
capables
de nous réconcilier
avec lui
et donc nous voyons
que cette distance
spirituelle
fait que Christ
après sa souffrance
à la croix
sa mort
il ressuscite
et c'est là
où nous voyons
l'accomplissement
de cette troisième distance
qui est la distance
temporelle
donc nous on a passé
quelques temps
à la recherche
d'un temple
Israël a passé
beaucoup plus
entre la période
du tabernacle
envers la période
du temple
se sont passés
480 ans
ensuite
ils ont réjoui
du temple
pendant plus ou moins
370 ans
après ils ont vécu
un exil
en silence
des 400 ans
et ensuite
donc 1500 ans
depuis le tabernacle
jusqu'à la venue
du Christ
1000 ans
depuis les temples
jusqu'à la venue
du Christ
et donc
si nous pensons
que cette attente
était dure
pour Israël
Dieu
il était en train
d'enseigner
qu'est-ce qu'il voulait
enseigner
les sens des merveilles
malgré votre petitesse
et sa grandeur
il est venu vers vous
malgré votre corruption morale
et sa pureté
il est venu vers vous
et apprenez à chérir
car tous ces temps
passés
en attente
c'est pour savoir chérir
qui est dans la plénitude
des temps
née d'une femme
née sous la loi
Dieu a envoyé son fils
et qu'est-ce que
Christ il fait
il accomplit les temples
en sa personne
étant lui-même
courte par exemple
l'habitation des dieux
mais
une fois mort
et ressuscité
il amène
son corps
qui accomplit
parfaitement la loi
son corps
qui a été puni
proportionnel
à nos enfers
son corps
qui a été ressuscité
il monte aux yeux
et la Bible
il nous dit
que nos vies
sont cachées
en Jésus Christ
donc la plus grande
leçon
que nous pouvons tirer
de cette notion
des temples
c'est que nous vivons
dans la nouvelle alliance
une fois que Christ
est déjà monté au ciel
et qu'il a fait de nous
les privilèges
d'être habitation
du Christ
par son esprit
il envoie son esprit
il fait de nous
des pierres vivantes
et donc lorsque
nous nous rassemblons
nous devons toujours
préserver
ce sens des merveilles
les sens des merveilles
qui se montrent
entre nous
dans nos cultes
par deux choses principales
révérence
et réjouissance
sens des privilèges
et crainte
tant que notre église
cherche à cultiver
et à préserver
un sens des merveilles
car Dieu
habite entre nous
nous allons pouvoir
réjouir
non seulement
du fait
que Christ
est descendu
pour nous visiter
il y a 2000 ans
mais car aujourd'hui
à chaque fois
que l'église
se rassemble
comme nous présente
l'apocalypse
nous sommes élevés
en esprit
à la présence
des dieux
en Christ
il a pénétré
les sanctuaires célestes
il intercède pour nous
et c'est plus large
de l'alliance
qu'elle a
c'est la réalité
du trône céleste
où les anges
sont autour du Christ
et l'église
lorsqu'elle
célèbre
ses cultes
les dimanches
c'est comme si
on était en train
d'ouvrir une fenêtre
envers les trônes célestes
et un esprit
nous sommes co-participants
de la nature divine
et nous nous trouvons
en Christ
devant Dieu
pour l'adorer
et pour avoir
cet accès
et nous sommes co-participants
pour l'un des trônes